now if you believe the polls the snps
absolute dominance in Scottish politics
might be about to come to an end with
the Conservatives reaching into
unexpected parts of the country now one
man whose seat might just be in line to
turn blue is the SNP s Foreign Affairs
spokesman Alex Salmond and he joins us
now from his home in Aberdeen sure hello
thank you very much for being on the
program with us this morning
great to be here love it
now last month you said that this
election was about independence and that
people would be voting to support the
right of Parliament to decide on the
holding of a Scottish referendum now
Nicola Sturgeon seems to say that it's
not about independence so have you
changed your mind or do you stand by
what you said no there's no difference
between what what decklist Archer says
and I say that's because I support
Nicola Sturgeon I mean there is about
three things Sophie
it's about pervading the real opposition
to Tory government that only there
simply have been providing and only the
SNP can provide it's about asserting
Scotland's right to at least maintain or
a place within the single market it says
we can protect 80,000 Scottish jobs
otherwise would be lost whether your
leave or remain whether your for
independence and against that that's an
immediate priority in this election and
yes it's about saying that Scotland's
future when the time is right should be
decided by the Scottish Parliament and
the Scottish people that Scotland's
future should be in Scotland's hands
these are the three priorities that the
SNP have in this election well I can
understand why you're not putting
independence at the forefront there of
your pitch during the election because
there hasn't been a single poll has
there since the Scottish referendum that
shows a majority support independence
well that's not true Sophia the sights
they've been five polls but perhaps the
most interesting poll in terms what I've
just been saying it was the servation
poll conducted at the very early part of
last month which asked people's got the
simple question who should decide on
whether there should be an independence
referendum should it be the Scottish
Parliament and the Scottish people or
should it be Theresa May and Westminster
and the answer to that question was 60
40 60 percent said that Scotland's
future should be
Outlands hands that's why it's one of
the key priorities for the SNP in this
election so oppose a Tory government
make sure we maintain our place within
the single market place that Scotland's
voice is heard immediately and thirdly
to make sure that the Scottish
Parliament and the Scottish people have
the right to decide our own future and
on that basis I'm confident that the SNP
will win this election have the most
seats the most votes of any other
political party well with respect it is
a bit different talking about polls that
say that Scotland should be able to
decide their future and talking about
support for independence itself but
you're saying that Scotland not Sophie
the Sophie Sophie there have been five
polls which have shown majority support
on the question of Scottish independence
I was merely saying that given Teresa
Mays attitude of what was it now is not
the time because it was a time for the
general election but now is not the time
for a referendum it's interesting that
whether the views on the independence
question people in Scotland by a
substantial majority support the idea
that these things now should be decided
by the Scottish Parliament and the
Scottish people not by Theresa May in
London now you say that you're
confidently the SNP will be the biggest
party after this election but if the
Conservatives do make up ground as the
poll suggests that they may be do you
think that is suggesting a surge in
support for unionism or do you think
there's something else that will be an
explanation for that
well if you look at the local elections
when the SFP support was absolutely
solid what happened was it was a
transfer of support from the Labour
Party to the Conservative Party if you
take the the big Ashcroft survey
published on Friday and in the papers
this morning it says the SNP could get
between 45 and 48 seats and Scotland
depending on tummo
now that was surveyed at the end of of
last month I think we can do better than
that because as the election focuses on
these three issues of prevailing the
real opposition to Tory government of
making sure we maintain our place within
the single marketplace and of having
Scotland's future and Scotland's hands I
think lots of people in Scotland I'm
going to to rally to that banner the
same time you're about 10 percent down
in the polls
roughly compared to the last general
election do you think that's partly
the domestic record of the SNP I mean
we've had some figures coming out this
week showing less and a half of thirty
and forty
thirteen and fourteen year olds in
Scotland are performing well in writing
I mean you are failing
Scotland's children aren't you with
those literacy standards well firstly
Sophia is 10 years almost exactly since
the SNP came to government we we won
that historic election in 2007 on 52% of
the vote there hasn't been a single poll
in this election which shows the SFB at
less and 40 percent of the vote and
therefore to increase your support over
10 years and government is he
substantial achievement and that
reflects the satisfaction that the SNP
have that the people of Scotland have in
an SNP government but on education that
have challenges on Scottish education
Nicola Sturgeon has made it her top
priority but let's remember right now
Sophie that 93 percent 93 percent of
children in Scotland now gone to
positive destinations to college the
university to apprenticeships or to jobs
and we've got the thud loss rate of
youth unemployment in Europe and then in
terms of higher education we're not just
have record passes at school but 55% of
Scottish children go into higher
education at college which we do in
Scotland at university the figure
England this forty five percent so these
are not signs of an education system
that's failing on the country these are
signs of success but necklace dodging
has made a top priority to address the
challenges that are in Scottish
education which is why she's put 120
extra million pounds into the hands of
head teachers a time when we know in
England the debate is how much school
budgets are falling in many parts of the
country but you actually say you've been
in power for ten years now and I just do
want to talk about that record or
literacy because it is shocking less
than half of 13 and 14 year olds not
performing well and also if you look at
other stats the number of
eight-year-olds performing well a
reading dropping as well I mean do you
feel a sense of shamed if you're worried
about this no well so let's connect to
that the the subway of talking about
measures people at second school in the
second year compared to the for the
performance they must attain in the
third year actually when they get to
third year the performance is over
80% of people performing well and yes of
course it's an important survey and
that's where Nicholas dozen is
addressing the challenge in terms of the
attainment fund but let's not dismiss
the fact that you should judge an
education system by its outcomes and if
you have as we have right now in
Scotland the record 93% of children
going on to positive destinations and
the subd lowest youth unemployment rate
in Europe then your something is growing
very well and Scottish education and
perhaps occasionally the network media
might might acknowledge that it's not
just at school so is it and the NHS
targets are also being missed in
Scotland poverty is on the rise the
police are facing a black hole I mean
it's if this is a flavour of an
independent Scotland you can see why a
lot of people in Scotland are a bit
concerned about the reality of it can't
you well let me correct you Sofia the
NHS in Scotland again has challenges as
any public service does but it's easily
the best performing National Health
Service across these islands across the
UK in 10% better for example an accident
and emergency figures maybe we saw this
week the Labour Party pledging to abide
by the Nazis peel of you we've done that
in Scotland which is why a band five
nurse gets paid 300 pounds more in
Scotland and the same nurse in England
you know that's why our junior doctors
huh begin and strike in Scotland because
we have a better performing National
Health Service despite the many
challenges it exists but their actual
help services got by any measurement is
the best performing in the UK and
perhaps that's because we spend 7
percent more per head on our health
service than you do in England so for
judging on performance and remember you
know with great respect we're not going
to be judged in terms of network media
but the people of Scotland have returned
the SNP twice into government after her
initial win in 2007 so Sophie we we must
be doing something right to get the
chuttan twice more into government
you're supremely confident of course
about the SNP prospects in the election
perhaps unsurprisingly but the
Conservatives and Ruth Davidson have
said that they are specifically
targeting your seat in in Gordon in the
local elections the Conservatives
actually beat that
Sen P into second place so we use time
to fill a few butterflies in your
stomach you nervous at all about your
own prospects in the election well not
not in terms of counselor Sophie we want
more pencils than the seat of Godin and
the Conservative Party viv but listen
I'm quite pleased actually for two
reasons that roof Davidson has made this
beam glorious boast about sweeping the
country and winning garden it means
firstly [ __ ] the northeast of
Scotland don't like that sort of thing
they like people talking after the match
not before the match it but secondly of
course the Tories have said they're
going to unseat me at the previous main
elections and have failed nine times and
as they concentrate the resources in
Scotland in the Gordon it although
although SNP candidates to win across
the rest of the country so in there some
famous words that were once used to be
by another opposition leader let me say
it to Jeru feed Iverson but I get on
bring it on do you think that the
Conservatives now your main threat in
Scotland rather than labour
well the Labour Party have been leaking
votes but remember you know despite this
talk about this big Tory revival you
know in many areas of Scotland the
Conservative Party are simply not
competitive and I I'm not making a boss
about the SNP winning every seat but
what I can see and what is true is that
in all 59 Scottish seats
the SNP are competitive that we are
trying to win in each of the seats of
Scotland that doesn't mean we'll win
them all of course but it means that at
least were competitive no other party in
Scotland can claim that and no other
party in Scotland has a realistic chance
of winning this election in terms of
seats and votes and will winner on these
three priorities making the opposition
to this dominant Tory government in
England opposition is required
preserving Scotland's placed within the
single market to protect Scottish jobs
and making sure that the future of
Scotland that Scotland's future's
decided by the Scottish Parliament and
the Scottish people that Scotland's
future must remain as Scotland's hands
now we know of course you want people
surveyed at SNP in the election but no
matter how many seats the SNP win the
Prime Minister is going to be Theresa
May or Jeremy Corbyn so who would you be
more comfortable with in number 10
Theresa May or
me : well I mean I think it's generate
noise we're not going to be in a hung
parliament situation that their concerns
as a heading towards a large victory
we've made it quite clear that the espys
on the progressive side of politics and
we don't make a alliances where the
Conservative Party locally or nationally
because of the damage that they are
doing to Scotland as a country but also
to the vol nerble the disabled in
Scotland you know Sophie I've been in
our Westminster Parliament some time ago
but the Tories had a large majority and
it was not a good outcome for the people
it wasn't a good outcome for Scotland it
wasn't a good a place to be disabled or
to be vulnerable in society
Tory large majorities are not something
for anyone to wish for it to express
election are going to rally well we're
not going to allow you to conservative
party under any circumstances but the
reality in this election is not who's
going to win it because the Tories are a
street ahead so for the border it's
whether there's going to be real strong
opposition and very very few people in
this country nor four so for the border
want to see an untrammeled hard right
Tory government that's why we need the
opposition that the SNP can provide